[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett we do this every
single week we have an up close and
personal conversation with someone
interesting from the internet this week
mr. Shane Dawson joins us at the round
table of dim lighting we discussed life
changing ghost encounters what is like
growing up wing twice as much as you do
now and how YouTube got him fired among
other things it's a great conversation
stay tuned for that but first link I
want to just make a request of me or the
people of you well I have a goal and
since a lot of times we spend a lot of
time together if I have a goal then a
lot of times you can help me achieve
that goal and I think this is gonna be
something that you're also gonna be into
is that all I am to you Rhett got
accountability someone to help you
achieve your goals I feel used
yep okay what is it we should go to more
concerts I've been thinking about this
lately I've been thinking about the fact
that we live in this town where pretty
much any band any artist who is anybody
is gonna have a date on their tour
that's true they're gonna come through
this town and they're gonna play music
and you can usually you can find out
about this before it happens it's not
like the kind of thing it this isn't the
medieval times or just like a troubadour
comes in as well
waltz here yeah love the trumpet and you
just come around yeah we have the
internet and Walt is that what you said
that's a very medieval name for this is
a very fruit bat or famous medieval
performer I am walked anyway it the last
concert we went to in this town you
remember that Merle Haggard and Kris
Kristofferson and I gotta tell you
forget it at the Greek theater amazing
venue obviously amazing performers
life-changing experience for us row
third row and then we stayed after the
concert and we waited for Merle we
stayed out there we had talked with
somebody we kind of got in a little bit
and we got into the like two fangirls
that's the backstage area but we got
into
like the the VIP area where the
apparently Kris Kristofferson and Merle
Haggard were going to come in to at
least rumor had it they were gonna come
in there after they performed and eat
because I mean guys and girls ladies and
gentlemen you have to understand that
Merle Haggard is he's not only a musical
icon he is a personal icon for us he is
like a North Star of being for us I mean
he's not a god I'm not gonna say it kind
of sounds like we're big fans of Merle
Haggard I mean I have so many records
there's not a god but we really like him
we really loved Merle Haggard and I mean
our collective goal in life is to meet
him before he dies I mean he's gonna go
some Johnny Cash is gone Waylon Jennings
is gone I was not gone I was prepared to
pee a little bit among me you know when
meeting him what would happen it upon
meeting him is where I was trying to say
we didn't meet him he was sick he was
feeling under the weather which is not
unusual for Merle at this age but I
don't want to wait for marula come back
to Los Angeles to see another concert
that really wasn't my point what it
wasn't to reminisce about that it was
about the fact that we enjoy music we
some people would say our musicians I
enjoy a great live show you know we can
get a babysitter we can take our wire
I'm talking about you know how wives are
invited that's nice if I decided hey I
hear about these shows I hear about
these bands I hear about these places
and I know that there are people
actually going to enjoy these things and
here we I mean here we are in a room
with each other at night and that's
great I enjoy that but I'm saying
occasionally we should be going to a
concert it's okay I have two thoughts
first it's a certain special type of
person I've observed that goes to
concerts I mean at a younger age
everyone so yeah I'm gonna go to show or
whatever you know when we were in
college we saw a decent amount of
concerts but for an older person someone
who's out of college to go to a concert
my observation is that that is a certain
type of person that we are not and
that's one a rich person to a person who
doesn't have any
thing doesn't have a lot of kids I think
is what it is I mean I think it's you
know you can't take your kids you have
to make it a priority I know there's
people you know that gays price and go
to things all that they go to these
concerts all the time and it is the
commitment I'm not just talking about
going to a concert that cost $90 or
something I'm just talking about a band
that's playing somewhere live music I
will say when the Avett Brothers come to
town we should work that out we should
go there we big fans there's we should
go and then but I'm not gonna wait
afterward like a schoolgirl and try to
meet him but if you know them anyone out
there knows them personally they're not
a song about my sister-in-law well I've
heard that a million times look at where
that's gotten us nowhere I'm I'm tired
of hearing about it honestly because you
can't work it into an angle for us to
meet them I mean let me tell you a
little something about the avett
brothers and then we'll move on and talk
to Shane Dawson they're from North
Carolina with their fingers they're from
North Carolina and Scott Avett one of
the - Ava brothers we kind of had a
thing with my wife's sister in college
at East Carolina University and he wrote
a song about her pretty girl from Cedar
Lane her name's Ashley she's the Ashley
in the song and we went so you say I
know for a fact and we went to the Khan
has it gotten us anywhere we went yeah
well we went to the concert the New
Year's Eve show this past year and you
know where Ashley set she said in a with
me in the back row the absolute furthest
spot away from the avett brothers so
that's what getting a song written after
you because we think it might be
inappropriate to try to work that angle
that's all I'm saying but a vet brothers
if you're listening anybody emailed them
what do you mean it's inappropriate you
email them I'm bitter about all of you
this years ago two years ago I said
opposites listen we make Internet videos
but enough about that
my sister-in-law you wrote a song about
her and we want to meet you guys it is
kind of a weekend yeah I got it but what
make a music video for you guys
we will it'll be awesome I also wanted
to see Willie Nelson
the Hollywood Bowl I haven't gone to
show at the Holi well I'll see anybody
there it's pathetic link it's a while
Ritchie is gonna be at the Hollywood
Bowl next morally but we're gonna be out
of town in North Carolina when he's here
it's a world renowned venue so um it's a
bowl it's a bowl well of course it is
that's why it's called Hollywood Bowl
okay this week we talked to Shane Dawson
you know him from his very popular
YouTube channel Shane Dawson TV's been
around since 2008 he's got just under
five minimum a million subscribers on
that channel on his second channel which
is youtube.com slash Shane his vlog
channel he's got under just under three
million subscribers over there and he
just launched I mean I guess it's been a
couple of months now his own audio
podcast called Shane and Friends which
is doing really well not not come knock
not a competitive podcast though we're
not in competition with it don't get
discouraged don't get discouraged your
biscuits is not in direct competition
with Shane your friends because if it
was we would lose I think that's my
point of trying make myself feel better
it's just a different thing we sit down
with Shane here it is
convo it up so let's start this off
right you had ghosts in your house still
do and you're selling it well I'm not
selling it because of that that was
definitely a reason but something I left
off the you know like buy this house
card did write free ghosts yeah my
grandma's here no so I my grandma died
and I never ever believed in ghosts ever
and she died in the house no she I don't
know where she died I don't know Long
Beach she's even worse
so she died back in Long Beach and you
know I was really really close to her
and one night I was laying in bed you
know watching friends or something and I
look over at the closet and she was
standing there and I've never you know
I'm not into all that weird go so it
freaked me out I ran out of my room I
threw up in the hallway I was like
hyperventilating my brother ran in and
my brother out of nowhere cuz he's not
into that stuff either he goes did you
see grandma and I
said what how do you know that he's like
cuz I heard her voice he's like 28 so we
both are like little girls screaming and
crying my mom runs up and my mom who's
like Christian but not into ghosts
either she stops us and she goes I know
what happened cuz I can feel it and calm
down it's just grandma we're like it's
just grandma she's dead so we go back to
my closet and I look and when she died I
didn't take any of her like valuables
but I took this one robe that she used
to wear everyday because I'm creepy as
hell so I took her rope and it was
hanging in my closet and that's right
where I saw her yeah it was creepy as
hell how long ago was this this was
about two years ago and then I stopped
sleeping in that room I created a
bedroom in my garage I had a converted
and I slept in my grudge for the next
year you let grandma have your bedroom I
was like you can have it grandpa I Robot
you can have the robe you can have it
all
um and then I went to my sorry I'm going
I'm talking too much about this is no
rabies no no this is interesting
probably not true but interesting so
then I was having a lot of really weird
experiences in that house so my
girlfriend's mom's friend is like a
medium who has like salt crimes and
she's you know done all that stuff okay
this is Lisa we know Lisa Lisa Lisa's
mom's friend is a medium okay and which
you know I thought was stupid and shady
but I looked her up and she's like legit
found dead bodies and like solve crimes
and like has done a lot of good things
I'm like okay let me go see her I didn't
tell her anything I sat down with her
and she goes your grandma standing right
next to you described my grandma said
her name did all this stuff what had
Lisa told her before you go through
nothing I told her not to she's like no
I won't because you know I want her to
be honest or whatever and she just
grabbed my grandma and goes your grandma
tried to reach you in your closet and
I'm like yes and she goes she was trying
to tell you when she went into what she
was trying to tell me and then she goes
no you keep you'd rather not tell us
because what was the nature of it oh the
long story what's the specific long
story short is I was working a little
bit too hard and was leading toward a
breakdown which is true and luckily I
listened to that advice and I didn't
have a breakdown but you know how it is
with YouTube and all these things you're
doing a million things sure and you
where's
self-doubt oh yeah so that happened and
I was like okay I get it thanks grandma
but she also said tell your mom that
your grandma wants to tell her to get
rid of all your grandma stuff because my
mom started putting my grandma all over
the house was a little strange and and
my grandma and she's the medium said
your grandma thinks your mom is making a
shrine of her and that's not healthy and
she needs to get rid of the shrine so
she can move on I go home and I said mom
and not I'm not lying my mom goes and my
mom goes Shane I just had this weird
feeling and I look over there's a box of
stuff I'm like what's going on she's
like something just told me to like
start taking down grandmas things like
it's almost like I have a shrine of her
her serious words I started bawling I
called Lisa I'm like oh my god your
mom's friends been real I like it got
really scary my mom started crying we
had this whole thing and I'm like okay
we I think I'm going to get my mom into
her own little house I think I'm gonna
sell this house so it definitely was
part of the reason I need to get some
stress off of my back so even though you
received guidance from your grandmother
you said I'm still still good now we're
still getting out of this house part of
the reason though was because the house
was a huge load of stress you know I
bought a big house and that was not I
mean it was smart but it also was like
you know huge monkey on my back you know
it's huge house that my mom is living
that I'm filming and that my all my dead
grandma stuff is in that it's like it
was I needed it clear some so it wasn't
just grandma that said but she is part
of the reason that I decided to finally
sell it because I wasn't going to and
after that I was like I think grandma's
telling me to sell this house did she
show up again or just that one time no
she never showed up again one good
one-time deal one time that's all it
took she got her point across it sounds
like I mean but you know it's funny
because I I still am very weary of when
people say goodbay believe in all this
stuff but I mean it legit happened and
it was real it was really terrifying to
see a dead person standing in front of
you well let's go back even earlier than
two years ago okay when grandma in the
closet and go to Grandma in real life we
you know living grandma yeah right
where you from where'd you grow up Long
Beach Oh LD say where's your grandmother
Danny uh and Cameron Diaz and Snoop Dogg
those are the only people
oh and the woman from Reno 911 one lives
there really
Wendy something yeah and if you go to
Long Beach's Wikipedia page we are there
how often do you go back to Long Beach
never you don't miss it
well it's not that far first of all it
is it's not but it is it's far enough
that you would have to decide to go back
there's no reason to go back is what
you're saying it's the worst drive ever
for so maybe since we've been there for
a couple of things he your son had a
dive meet in Long Beach you did
uh-huh and that's what that's the one
time I went that was it not too great
not too bad one there's a wharf down
there right what I call it way away like
a wharf like a big pier and I don't mean
like a dog making it I got excited cuz I
thought you meant like dwarf which is I
mean incorrect there's a dwarf hybrid
there a whale hybrid down there is
called the wharf
there is a rumored dwarf town have you
heard about this in Long Beach yes hey
you all you've heard about [ __ ] this
is so sorry little people found [ __ ]
tone you've heard about just give it to
a straight okay [ __ ] town have you
heard about that no no but I want to
is it within Long Beach here's the thing
I think every town has this rumor
obviously your guyses didn't but [ __ ]
town for those listening maybe they've
heard is supposedly there's a town in
every town we're just little people
living all the houses are small
everybody has a story like yeah me my
friends were there one night we got
drunk and we hit a [ __ ] with our car
like everybody has a [ __ ] town story
mm-hmm but there is actually a [ __ ]
town in Long Beach and that's why the
stories got created are there signs
yeah it's called short Beach probably
shouldn't I said is there something I
have not been there but it's very very
gated so it's not around it's not around
anymore
okay what it was was when they were
filming was heard of Oz I have so many
weird facts I'm sorry oh no I have heard
about this yes yes on NPR they talked
about all the munchkins at the time they
were filming yeah live there and you
you know they stick together they bought
a bunch of little places and you know
how do much a little house is and and
houses are still there how I think the
houses are still there but there's I
don't think anybody's living there we
talked to the security guard and like a
bunch of people around the area and they
were all very like casual about like oh
yeah that was a you know historical
place blah blah blah I'm like oh so it's
real alright so give us some of the
details of growing up in Long Beach
well besides our endless searches for a
[ __ ] town um oh god I I don't even
know I grew up with both your parents
your grandma how did this work no okay
so I grew my dad left kind of left I
don't know what he left I guess that's a
word for it when I was about nine and
then I lived with my mom and my grandma
v grandma the grandma okay got it
brothers and sisters my brother two
brothers yes - sometimes I just forget
family that sounds terrible you forget
how many brothers you have no just
family and God yes two brothers
there's so many pictures I mean thank
that other the other brother he's in
pictures I've never met him no but I was
looking through pictures the other day
when cuz we're you know we're moving
we're cleaning and I saw this picture of
me my brother and some little girl Mike
who the hell is that my mom's like oh we
had a daughter for a while I'm like what
do you mean you had a daughter for a
while she's like well we it just didn't
work out I'm like that doesn't make any
sense
yeah can you explain like a foster kid I
think what it was is my mom couldn't
physically she always wanted a daughter
and she kept having sons and I think at
some point she's like physically this
isn't gonna happen so I'm gonna get a
daughter and I think through a church
she started adopting one but I think
something bad happened with the daughter
maybe she was possessed I don't know but
it didn't work out huh I think the
original parents took her back it was
some weird sounds like a foster
situation lifetime it's right but you
have two brothers we're going on record
you grew up with two brothers one of
them was very absent so but so I really
grew up with one okay okay I think I've
met that brother the absent one no no
I'm like where where I haven't seen them
in so long but it wasn't the one that
you stay in touch with I just be in
touch with both but you bet yeah I think
you guys met the UH the one I grew up
with right
Jared Jared okay so so what was it like
you and Jared grown up with your mom and
grandma it was rough well oh yeah we
were very messed up kids cuz you know we
had such a messed-up upbringing so we
were constantly trying to find attention
and love and we were going nuts we would
wrestle and literally he threw me
through a glass door one time it didn't
hurt I was 400 pounds by the way I think
I missed that but he threw me through a
glass door we would get into these crazy
fights the cops would be called out as
sometimes we'd get kicked out of
churches in restaurants we were very
looking for attention when we were about
you know at nine ten years old so at
nine years old
your brother threw the 400-pound you
through a glass door here's the thing
though
it was an accident kind of we were
really into wrestling at the time and he
was trying to do like this Undertaker
move oh yeah and it just didn't just he
covered me in blankets so I was okay but
the move was he put me in blankets on a
chair and then he would run toward the
chair and he was trying with his arm and
he was trying to knock me out but then
he missed and I just flew through the
glass I can understand that Zach West
piledrive me in front of his grandma
when we were in middle school
and I never went to his house again I
was terribly embarrassed it was it was
pretty painful too you know
but mostly it was it was an ego pain
yeah with the grandma laughing and
everything but there was no punching did
your brother ever punch you no we loved
each other so much but we were I don't
know we we both have very high pain
thresholds I don't ever really feel pain
I'm sounding so weird in this interview
but it's fine I'm gonna go with it yeah
like I just got a I just got an ear
surgery and it was supposed to doctors
like you're gonna be out for three days
like it's gonna be the most pain you've
ever had you're gonna vomit I had Lisa
with me and she's holding my hand I'm
crying I'm nervous he did the whole
thing and I didn't even know he did it
he's like oh well you have hype like you
didn't feel that at all you have no
feelings what was the surgery for Oh God
I had this intense ear infection and
they had to drain my ear and poke holes
in it and put a tube in there and do a
bunch of weird stuff
cut things out you got a tube in there
right now I think it fell out it
dissolves yeah it falls out oh okay hey
you might need to make another
appointment okay that's not supposed to
have traditions dictate that you're
supposed to eat it when it falls out
good luck
yeah okay all right there's like a
mother eating the placenta which is also
good luck no and it's for I mean it's
becoming like the in thing out here in
California I'm not kidding okay so now
you're sounding weirder than me so this
is good no I'm just so sick I guess I
said that to ask now did your mom eat
the placenta after you were born because
that is kind of a thing no I'm not
kidding they dry it out and they put it
in tea and stuff no I used to be very
helpful I did poop in the placenta bag
and it almost killed my mother because
that could kill you yeah yeah yeah okay
so she didn't eat it now you said it how
much did you say you weight as a kid I
mean how much do you weigh now you're
like I'm like 175 now and you said you
weight how much my highest was I don't
know exact number my scale only went up
to 350 and I was always at error but I
lost a bunch of weight and then I was at
350 so I was probably at highest 400 and
this is you're talking like from a young
age like nine years old or younger I
mean I was always huge but I probably
was around 400 when I was like 14 okay
and you said that things were messed up
for you as a kid you're talking about as
a result of your dad not being there or
does something happen or what um I mean
I don't want to bring the mood to down
no you want me to bring it down yeah we
just want you to talk to us yeah we can
turn the lights out a little bit it's
fine
you're gonna get tears no you're not
I've no feelings no so my dad was not a
happy man
so he was not that friendly toward us
and loved the drinks phone um and and
yeah so he ended up leaving us for my
Spanish teacher slash mom's best friend
Oh know who's really cool I loved her
like a Mad Men situation yeah it was
intense and it's funny because when I
was a kid I didn't really get the full
story until now I look
back I'm like oh wow that was weird and
a lot but yeah so he left we were all
very excited when he left because you
know he was abusive and stuff so then me
and my mom my brother we lost everything
because he took everything so we like
lost our house and we were almost living
in our car one point and out of nowhere
our dentist was like oh you could rent
my old house for you know a fourth of
the price that I usually we rented out
so we were really lucky and blessed with
that so my mom started working she had
never had a job before she you know she
started working at like Macy's or
something and and we got our lives back
together and it was your dad completely
out of the picture at that point there
was no like visitation or no no I saw
him once in a while but but he wasn't
paying child support he wasn't helping
with anything I think it was it was very
Oh yuck he was terrible and that all
happened in the middle school years that
was from nine to about God I mean from 9
to 18 really but did all the bad
probably from like 9 to 13 okay and so
didn't you that's a really bad age for
those bad things to be happening I would
imagine food was great loved food
obviously so so food was a coping
mechanism for you at that time food was
definitely you know my my brother Jared
I'm sure he's fine with me going into
this because he's turned his life around
but he got into drugs and my other
brother got very into drugs to a point
where we didn't see him and I just loved
food and the bad thing is they always
say they always make excuses I go poor
people you know I'm sorry what is the
excuse well the excuses like oh it's so
expensive to eat healthy it's like no
that's true it's way too expensive to
eat healthy it was really cheap to eat
cans and cans of refried beans and in
government cheese that's what was cheap
for us right so I just got really big
but you know what I held it well I never
looked 400 I looked like 250 so I was
impressive I was lucky you still had
some mean wrastlin moves so many rats I
was really good at knocking my brother
out who was going through the door
just going through the door but yeah
yeah so I got really fat I'm sorry what
was the question
childhood I was fat what did I eat I
don't know what else well so so at that
age you said going in at a 14 basically
transition between middle school and
high school you go to a public school in
Long Beach so when when my dad was
around we went to a Catholic school
private school oddly enough he was very
high up in the church at the time we
were seven race to go Cardinal we were
like seven seven well so we went to a
Catholic school but the Christian Church
which was like the biggest Church in
Long Beach by Calvary Chapel or one of
those he was like the head guy their
minister I don't know
and we were all very up in that church
we went to a Catholic school which I was
always very confused about so when all
that went down we got kicked out of the
school and it was like a big controversy
so I had to go to public school which I
was excited about because you know
private schools terrible and yeah and I
went to public school for the rest of of
school and we were pretty broke forever
up until like I was 19 maybe right you
know right when I think long beach
public high school I think like typical
California and a movie high school am I
wrong about this well unless you're
thinking of like mmm like say the last
dance high school I can't say for sure
cuz I haven't seen it but the word beach
is in the town so I'm just eating on a
surfboard like learning math on the key
I don't I mean all schools are cliquey
but I just have this like California
high school there's the cool kids
there's the jocks there's the beach guys
there's the Hispanic kids so Long Beach
is cut into two slices one half is like
lesbians and like old retired why people
which is this nicest half that's like
Sherman what's it called Belmont Shore
that's where they film Dexter because it
looks like Miami like that's the cool
there's an aquarium there which I was a
I was a security guard for the octopus
at one point we'll get to that way yeah
yeah we will get to that like okay go
ahead but then there's the other half of
Long Beach which is where I grew up
which is just like all the black kids
which explains a lot about me all the
Mexicans I was one of the only white
people there and yeah so I was
definitely on that side of Long Beach
closer to Lakewood which does not have a
lake and they did at one point probably
ed woods - yeah so yeah I was I was in
that that area of Long Beach so my mic
crowd was um all black people and and
this sounds racist and whatever I guess
it's going to but I had I definitely got
picked on a lot being a 400-pound white
lesbian looking boy I had to form a
sense of humor and I and I really took
from the black culture and I started
creating jokes out of the movies they
were watching the music they were
listening to all this stuff so my humor
is very very black and it still is
pretty black so I'm good but you had I
mean you said that you were made fun of
but you had legitimate friends who were
are you saying your friends made fun of
you or everyone else but you had your
friends who were black people who taught
you what was funny
no I didn't really have friends I had
like one friend every year and they were
all so I mean I had a friend who was
like in a wheelchair and like I mean
let's just say god I don't want to say
[ __ ] I've already said [ __ ] Oh
Lord whatever I had a [ __ ] friend I
was I was the president of Best Buddies
which is a program in school where you
befriend a [ __ ] person and you take
to the movies and you like go to
Disneyland with them and I was the
president I know I'm a giver
after her Francis we're friends on
Facebook shut up every year Francis
every year I had a friend who definitely
was like and somebody who needed me no I
guess I was trying to like fix people
and help people or whatever and around
but I mean Paul's because that's pretty
and that is pretty remarkable I mean I
remember what we were like in that age
and not that we were you know
I'm not gonna say that we were the kind
of guys that were gonna you know point
out somebody who has some challenges it
make fun of them but then we I was
definitely not the kind of guy that was
like oh but I'm also going to befriend
this person much less be the president
of the best is the best buddies clubs
buddies but I'm still kicking I mean
that's I think that says a lot about who
you were who you are mm-hmm well you
know when you have no control at home
you and you you can't really get
anything together at home you can't like
being what's the word for you can't
really help anybody because you're the
youngest kid and you can't really do
much you can't get money for your mom
you can't do anything so when you go to
school and you see like these special
kids who have no friends and you see
this thing you're like oh I can help
these people you know I I don't have
money but I can I have time and I could
hang out with these kids and like
they're just as bored and lonely as I am
and I did a lot of stuff like that from
like sixth grade to ninth grade a lot of
like you know community service type of
stuff just because you know better than
sitting at home and eating well not as
great but but you were finding at the
time that you know being funny mm-hmm
was and they were the best audience it
was a way to deal with this insecurity
it was a way to deal with being a target
essentially hmm how it happened do you
remember a specific moment where was
like oh this works yeah I started drama
class at the beginning of high school
and and there was one skit and I went to
the teacher and I said oh can I write my
own skit and he's like okay so I did one
where I played like a gangster character
and I played a couple characters and I
did it in front of like you know my
class and they loved it and the next day
they're like do it in front of the whole
school during this assembly and I'm like
oh okay and I did it for the whole
school and I mean it was nuts every
person that auditorium was standing up
at the end of it freaking out I read it
I read the skit back a couple years ago
this is terrible but in high school they
loved it and that really turned
everything around and that's when I was
like oh I could actually you know do
something funny and people will laugh
and that's when I started making videos
and so used to you're talking about
starting youtube at that time YouTube
wasn't around this was like 2003 2004 so
I
just making videos for class projects
okay that was part tenth grade and I
would make these crazy raunchy you know
class projects and of course the teacher
was like shut and locked the door so the
principal didn't come in and we watch
them and laughing we made crazy raunchy
videos that your teacher okay we did
yeah pacifically what well like an
economics class we had to do something
about dictatorship so I did a bra I did
a short film I guess about me
about my little group and the whole
world ends and now me and my little
group are in charge of the whole world
so I'm like oh god I don't know how to
be the president let me read some books
so I read like a Hitler book and I'm
like this guy's awesome so then I come
back and I you know I look like Hitler
and I'm you know making people do all
these crazy things and we you know we
there was an Asian girl in our group and
she was eating all the animals like it
was very very offensive is this on VHS
somewhere it's on YouTube some I think
one of my teachers uploaded it what yeah
and it's a lot of views and it's flagged
which is like I'm gonna monetize this
what is it called Hitler High School and
did it did pretty well but but yeah so
the teachers were passed around my
videos to all the other teachers and it
was like this big thing and and yeah
that was before YouTube and I did that
like for project so you went viral
amongst two teachers at your high school
it was very weird yeah and once in a
while like they take me aside and be
like saw your Hitler High School video
funny I was like you see what see I
think that's that's one of the
differences between the long beach
experience and then the harness central
experience and we wouldn't have gotten
very far with the Hitler High School now
would have been shut down real fast
we made some racially insensitive videos
involving American Indians and we did in
middle school I remember that well you
did a horrible impression what I
actually know it's time to come clean
about two things that are very relevant
to this conversation the first thing is
if you do not recall you played a
mentally handicapped person in that
video that we made for class yes I did
you did and I play a Native American
at some point you don't plan and the
cameras rolling and you just you go into
the first care and make a choice but
yeah in your defense I will say that we
had read Of Mice and Men and we thought
that this was going to be a tasteful
portrayal of a mentally handicapped
person it wasn't like it wasn't so much
so hey let's do this it'll be funny you
play a mentally handicapped person and
I'll play a Native American defending
his land but because we were trying to
be funny it ended up being funny and
definitely very insensitive and there is
no record of it and it will never make
it on the Internet yeah none of the
teachers are going to monetize our well
it's just the age is the age difference
it's just the fact that were that much
older that they're you know those
teachers are dead now well between
YouTube starting just give me a give me
a we need to graduate from high school
just to get an idea graduated in oh six
okay so that was the same time that
YouTube large yeah so make some
connection there between making videos
that go viral with your teachers to
putting videos on the internet what what
are the specifics there so I started
putting up you know meet my friends
right after high school right after we
graduated I decided I was going to lose
weight because I was tired of being you
know the funny fat guy and I wanted to
be a director and an actor and I wanted
to not just be Chris Farley cuz you know
how that turned out
so he died he died for children he died
he had already died he had already died
got it yeah
so um so I but you haven't seen him
since no she's good don't put a jacket
up in your closet oh I've so many small
- I don't have any small ones luckily so
you wanted to lose weight lost weight so
that that first year after high school I
was making videos with my friends
putting them up on YouTube nobody was
watching and during that time I lost 200
pounds so one question was this this
your current channel or was it another
channel now this was like Shane yeah
it's not there anymore
I don't even remember deleting it but
it's gone okay yeah and then in the in
the process of this you lost how much
I'm bad at math about I'm like 175 my
Lois was like 165 and I think my highest
was 400 so over 200 pounds yeah
inhale and what period of time a year
how does that even safe you know what
for guys it's okay so I lost it on Jenny
Craig for the most part and then I
actually started working for Jenny Craig
about halfway through my weight loss
because I needed a job and I would start
seeing like I would notice guys lose
weight so fast I had one guy loose like
300 pounds in a year it was insane women
this is once you started working there
yeah so okay I know how Weight Watchers
works that like has point totals you
just basically manage your calories
Jenny Craig is that the same thing or is
that drinking shakes Jenny Craig oh I
wish no Jenny Craig is like eating Lean
Cuisines and then having to talk to
somebody for an hour a week about it
it's like the prepackaged meals are sent
to your house right no you have to go in
it's like going to the grocery store and
talking to the clerk about your problems
there's a store got a counselor
basically we're gonna count someone that
held you accountable yes counseled you a
chubby buddy but there's a place to go
and buy the food yeah so you go there
and it looks like a doctor's office from
the 80s it's the worst place ever
there's pictures of d-list celebrities
everywhere and you walk in you sit down
with your chubby buddy they weigh you
they tell you how much weight you lost
and then they order your food and say
what do you want this week and you buy a
bunch of food which is all very
expensive and there's a freezer room in
the back they bring it out in bags and
you leave and this still goes on yeah so
you were going in there and you were
seeing results I mean you were losing
all types of weight and you decided to
get a job with them well I couldn't
afford the food anymore so about halfway
through my weight loss like I my mom was
trying so hard
I was working on these random jobs
security guard and octopus who are you
guarding docked if I was from the people
I yes vice versa he was the ninth and
tenth arm that was good guiding the
octopus children really liked to get in
there and touch time to push and you
can't do that so I would like hold their
ankles so yeah all day I would tell them
no touching the octopus
that was my Gordon but help me get Jenny
Craig food and then about halfway
through I lost that job well they just
the octopus they didn't need me I mean
let's be honest the octopus
yeah the octopus the octopus so you
applied for a job yeah because you get
your food for cheap like half off or
something and yeah I became a chubby
buddy and then over that what did you do
specifically so I would I started out as
just a counselor which is just like
somebody would come in I'd sit down with
them they talk about their week I'd give
them advice and then send them on their
way and I was really really good at it
and literally in like the first couple
weeks they promoted me from councillor
to manager I'm a hard worker the CEO
loved me promoted me to manager and I
was now managing all these people that
have worked there for 20 years I had
work there for two weeks
I was the biggest sales person in the
country at one point I'm really good at
selling Jenny chests about a Long Beach
know the country I mean I know but you
were getting out of Long Beach oh yeah
yeah yeah you get a plaque or something
no I well this is where this sorry I
feel like I keep steamrolling but so
long story short I worked the Jenny
Craig I was doing really well and I made
a video at work I've heard we've we've
heard of this I want to hear it from you
okay and at this point you were like the
top salesman in the country for Jenny
Craig
I was the shitty Craig not in real life
wasn't really making any money but I was
they would actually send me to
struggling other Jenny Craig centers to
like it was like a really Hilary Swank
Lifetime movie like across the country
no no like Orange County LA okay I would
go to like the Downtown Fullerton and I
would be the manager there for like a
month and like you know make everybody
work together and make the people love
everybody and sell a bunch of food and
then they'd fly me away to another
terrible place to work for a month and
they did that because I was really good
and I would turn these places around and
what do you what was it about you I mean
what was your secret okay
I had the before and after thing which
was which was you know really great to
show people although embarrassing
because you'd be like this is my before
and after picture and they'd be like
how'd you get that big oh my god when
did you eat so that was like a daily
constant reminder of my choices
but I have this speech because Jenny
Craig is very expensive so the whole
thing is you have to sell the program to
these people who don't really have the
money and you have to figure out how to
get the money so I came up with this
speech I was like okay listen so for
example say you need to lose weight so
and but be very hesitant to buy it ready
okay so the program is um it's a really
great it's a year long it's and yeah but
I you know I mean I'm just minimum wage
man listen
so am I you saw my before and after
picture I didn't even have a job at that
point I was struggling check check but
think about it this way and I'll go into
the speech and say you know like look at
your car for example say right now your
car totally broke down your tires fell
off your engine just blew up I don't
know anything about cars but all that
everything goes wrong with the car and
they give you a bill and say hey it's
$5,000 to fix your car you're gonna find
the money you're gonna split it between
cards are gonna call your mom you're
gonna do whatever you can to get that
car done because you need that car this
is your body yeah your body a lot more
than you need a car hmm and then they
cry and be like oh my gosh you're so
right and they'd sign it so at what
point would you mention the octopus and
then I'd say I used to work in an
aquarium if you really need money I left
there's an opening job
there's an opening of the aquarium okay
tonight tell us about the video then so
then okay another long story short
Valerie Bertinelli who was the
spokesperson at the time nobody
listening knows she knows who she is
probably what show was she on in the 80s
one day one day at a time
yeah the only reason I know that's cuz
the book was called like one pound at a
time right yeah terrible pun yeah so
Jenny Craig was like oh give this to all
of your new clients did you ever meet
Jenny no she sold the company to Nestle
chocolate before I started working there
which is of course she did little ironic
I mean when she did sell though all the
foods slowly turn chocolate which was
very weird like clients would be like
why are these chips chocolate what is
male and I'm everything just slowly
turned spaghetti all the yeah all the
protein was chocolate so no I never met
her but but yeah so her people were like
oh get about these Valerie Bertinelli
biography style your clients for free
and I'm like okay so I you know we were
right next to Leisure World which is
like old folks Disneyland it's all the
old people lived there
it's like a big community of old people
all my clients were like 80 so I gave
the book to them they're all excited to
come back the next week and be like did
you read this book before he gave it to
me and I'm like no I don't read so I
looked through the book and I was just
like oh my god every chapter I mean
chapter one cocaine a hell of a drug
chapter two who was that like every
chapter was intense she was like a child
star from the 80s and she had done all
this stuff so I thought it'd be funny is
if if I had some consultants and some
old clients read passages from the book
very seriously with music and lighting
and it was really really funny and I put
it up and literally the next day because
you had been making videos just on your
own like stupid vlogs this was
shanedawsontv my my my now channel so I
was making very like simple vlogs this
was my third video and what was your
expectation and putting it up nothing I
was just like oh I cut my hair and I
lost some weight I'll make a new channel
because my other channel I look like
Rosie O'Donnell so I need to rebrand
myself I guess and the third one was
this this one customers of Jenny Craig
Craig I want to say Craig because
there's an AI ya know it sounds good
customers reading excerpts from Valerie
Bertinelli's autobiography which was
really juicy really really really juicy
and I got a week not I didn't get a
phone call okay another long story short
my brother and my mom were working there
as well as a family affair I let him all
in so we're all at work and we're all
like talking about the video like it
wasn't that fun yesterday only that's so
funny it has ten views isn't that
awesome and then boom bust through the
door all these CEOs from Jenny Craig
like hardcore terrifying looking CEOs
lots of pantsuits and they they grabbed
me took me to like the office shut the
door and read me my rights kind of thing
and we're like sign that paper and
you're out and I was like wait what and
they were doing it to everybody in
separate offices so then we all ended up
in the parking lot everybody made your
brother in your mom my brother and my
mom and five other people that worked
there some who would work there for 25
years
oh you're kidding it was bad and we were
on the parking lot and everybody's like
what's going on oh my god and the CEO
walked out again there that you can't
ever be here ever you need to leave but
you we will send your stuff in the mail
you need to leave like it was like we
had committed a crime my mom had our
hands behind her back at one point like
handcuffs not handcuffs but like they
were as they were walking her out they
like acted like they handcuffed her I
think they were literally in front of
clients walking her out like a criminal
I was like but my before and after
pictures in there so much for being the
top salesman I know they didn't care
is this video still up you know somebody
reuploaded it though so it's up now and
what's it called I don't know what they
called it it was probably like Shane's
deleted Jenny Craig video or something
okay but how long was it up before their
you know the first hand views like
nothing yeah like 10 views it was crazy
nobody watched it I guess so
somebody at Jenny Craig watched her
maybe yeah you had to be somebody on the
inside if you weren't popular well
here's it there was one woman working
there who didn't get fired who hated me
because that was good
her she had been there for 20 years and
she was never promoted she hated me and
yeah I think she ratted us out for sure
[ __ ] okay so you lost your job well and
along with some other people then what
then I I'm not gonna lie I had a very
serious depression for like a while I
mean you know it caused everybody to
lose their jobs a lot of guilt my mom me
and my brother were all on unemployment
we were trying to find jobs and um I
tried to be a security guard again they
didn't want me so I'm but literally a
week later I think I got a phone call
from YouTube being like hey do you want
to be a partner and I was like what and
it was so early on and um and yeah that
gave me hope of course I got turned down
from being a partner because I didn't
have enough videos or something but I
was like you know what if I could make
more videos and really put my heart and
energy into this while on unemployment
maybe soon I could make this a job and
it happened like a few months later I
got partnered and what you're we don't
know like oh wait wait okay mm-hmm so I
mean so you must have had more videos
that gave them cause to contact you
for the revenue share I think at the
time you know what it was I made a video
the day I got fired called YouTube got
me fired
and that one did well because of the
title maybe I think it got like maybe
like five thousand views in a day which
for me back then was a lot you were just
telling the story mm-hmm and I was like
kind of crying in it but not really and
I was like upset about it I was wearing
a terrible ill-fitting vest it was all
very Jonas Brothers and and that one got
a lot of attention in the little YouTube
community at the time and I think that's
what they saw I think that was like my
maybe fourth video okay but then they
wouldn't let you in because you didn't
have enough videos and but then a few
months later you were making more videos
were you gaining traction yeah I went
from you know I had like 5,000 pieces on
that video and then I started getting
you know like 50,000 views and then I
think by the time I got partnered I was
getting like a hundred thousand views of
video what were the videos I started
doing I think about YouTube back then
and I'm sure obviously you guys know
this at the time there wasn't that many
people talking directly to the audience
and like engaging being like hey guys
what do you think about this topic and
I'd have a sketch and then I'd asked
them what they think about the topic and
I created like this cool group of kids
who felt very like they didn't fit in
very much like I felt and they're their
age and it was word of mouth I mean it
grew like I think it probably had maybe
a hundred thousand subscribers in like I
don't know a few months or something
like so it was a sketch what I mean what
we've grown to expect from your channel
it was a kind of a sketch thing that
then would have a sincere vlog
conversation with your audience tacked
on to the end of it yeah and like back
then I didn't I didn't do it - well I
always wanted to have a moral at the end
of the video cuz I you know it's how I
grew up I always wanted to help people
out and have a moral and I mean I watch
some of the older videos and I'm like
wow that sounded terrible because I
would have this crazy crazy video with
sex and drugs and all this stuff and
then at the end I'd be like guys I don't
drink and you shouldn't drink either
it's so bad
so public service announcement I wasn't
subtle at all but that was my goal was
to like spread do like after-school
specials on crack that was my goal yeah
it's interesting that I imagine a lot of
people I mean even my first impression
was
this guy will say anything he's thinking
and oh my gosh the kids who are
listening to this I'll listen to the
language or the topics that he's talking
about and and then at the end he's doing
this thing where it's kind of like
flipping it around it's but I guess I
was missing the point and not seeing
where you were coming from even now as I
appreciate your story that it was I mean
it was even very calculated you said you
weren't good at it but what would you
say or what was your experience
I guess dealing with those people all
along who would just react to the
content upfront and not really see what
you were trying to do I ignored it
because I knew what I was doing and I
you know when I was a kid I grew up on
horror movies not horror movie horror
horror horror horror movies I grew up
that's all I watched it's all I knew I
still that's all I watched really so I
have had it was so desensitized to
violence and cussing and boobs and all
of that stuff so for me I wanted to be
genuine and authentic with what I
thought was funny what I thought was
cool and I was into dark humor and all
that stuff and I was like maybe there's
other kids out there that are like that
too and when YouTube first started it
was those kids now it's a little more
mainstream but back then it was like the
dark gothic kids at school and that's
what they thought was funny too and my
first one of my first sketches was about
phone sex where I had phone sex with a
girl and she ended up like killing
somebody I don't know it was very dark
and and yeah like and that's just what I
knew and then the moral was phone sex
kills yeah the moral was there's always
youth if you think your life is bad
there's always somebody out there whose
life is worse than yours and you should
appreciate what you have it was always
like the morals were very very loosely
tied to it but um I mean has your has
your mission so to speak remain the same
you know here we are 2013 and we we all
know that YouTube has changed
dramatically it's so you know for guys
like you it's it's a it's a business I
mean this is what you do this is what
you're going to do for the foreseeable
future you're an entertainer now
full-time entertainer
how has the approach changed in terms of
are you still trying to get those morals
across or I still do once in a while but
for the most part because YouTube is now
so mainstream and it's not just to press
kids it's like everybody's watching
YouTube so I don't want to hammer in
morals every week because it gets a
little like preachy but for like once a
month I'll do a moral but but my whole
thing now is I look at it like okay now
my goal is just to give five minutes of
entertainment to somebody who needs it
and if there's moral great if there's
not at least I got five minutes of free
entertainment and and then hopefully now
just keep proving people like oh I can
actually direct because my goal now
which has been my goal since I was five
is to direct so now I'm not really in my
videos anymore and all my last like hit
videos I guess so hard nowadays to get a
hit but like my last couple like good
videos I haven't even been in like my
last couple parodies I wasn't even in
mmm just behind the scenes writing
directing so that's kind of my goal now
is to take a little step back yeah and
you know we've seen both of your recent
Miley parodies which it when I saw your
that we can't stop parody I was like
call my wife and I was like you've got
we've got to watch this because we
because we had just watched her video
and I was like I was just like Seamus
which was full of morals totally I mean
I did I love the way that you just
totally called her caught her out and
just kind of just you know you just
taught you just told the truth about
this situation and who is the who's the
girl that plays Miley and her name is
Kristen Finlay and she I've known her
the fine brothers introduced me to her
like six years ago or something five
years ago maybe she is a genius she's
the funniest person I've ever met and
she is one of the best actresses I've
ever ever worked with it's not even
directing I mean she just does it
I just film it like that's she's so good
yeah they were great I think one of the
things I'm interested in and we'll wrap
up here in a little bit but I'm
definitely interested in the being you
know the the shame that was the
overweight kid in high school that was
struggling with making friends so
definitely not the popular kid to all of
a sudden being the Shane Dawson
that we all know right we go to VidCon
and I remember the first VidCon it there
was just talk about how you couldn't get
from one side of the room to the other
and that you had to have security I was
like yeah that's I mean I for
embarrassing way you you know from what
you came from to that well you have to
have security when going into a
conference and then after every everyone
lines up for your autograph what is that
like for you it's weird it never I've
never been I've never felt like
empowered by it I've never been like
excited about getting recognized or like
I've never had like random meet like you
know as you'll see youtubers like let's
have a meet up guys cuz you know it's
like an ego boost it's validation I've
never had that where I need that but I
almost but I'm also not uncomfortable
with it it's like when I will go to
VidCon all the kids are there our
relationship is very much like friends
like they come right up to me that give
me a hug could tell me like their sad
story and then we hug it out take a
picture and they're gone it's very like
the way I would treat a friend
tell them Saul my sad stories and then
leave where is like you see a nowadays
YouTube is changing jour like you see it
the British youtubers walk in and it's
very like super star like kids don't
want to go up to them they're scared
they like taking pictures from far away
it's it's like the way you would treat a
real celebrity so but my audience is
still very like friends so it's just
felt like I have a lot of friends which
is definitely different for me right but
also people who know me sometimes better
than my real friends know me so I'm
never nervous or shy or uncomfortable
what do you I mean do you you know be
being somebody who struggled to make
friends and you know it was being made
fun of
and now being somebody who you've got
all these friends I mean you you see the
fans as friends and I totally understand
that we thats definitely it's very very
different the relationship between a
YouTube celebrity and a fan is much
different than any traditional celebrity
but how do you think that's impacted you
know do you do you find any sort of
security in that now you know I as an
example you know I came home the other
night and my wife I had a really hard
day and I said something I can't
remember what I said I said something an
insensitive that kind of just started an
argument and she she mentioned she said
I you know I've been here with your two
sons all day who have not been
appreciating me and what I've been doing
for them
you've been out there being a youtuber
with all these through these thousands
of people who appreciate you of course
there's the haters but then there's the
people who appreciate what you do and I
kind of it kind of hit me it's like yeah
you know it is true that you know once
you get to a certain level on YouTube
it's kind of like you're a you're some
you're someone who does something like
if it's good mythical morning it's every
single day it's a video every once in a
while people appreciate it you know and
I can't kind of hit me I was like you
know I wonder how much I'm kind of how
much how much that comforts me the fact
that there's all these people out there
who appreciate what I do for you
somebody who didn't necessarily have
that growing up now you've got it is how
are you dealing with that it's still a
lot of I still have a lot of like the
pressure to which is why I told you
earlier like I've gotten close to having
a breakdown because I take all these
kids or viewers or whatever you want to
call them I take all these kids problems
it's up on on me and I'm like well if I
don't have a new video out on Saturday
all these kids are gonna be disappointed
it's like so much pressure and then the
last year ever since my you know dead
grandma told me to chill I've definitely
like taken a backseat to some things and
like chilled out and been honest with
the audience and said listen guys I need
a break or listen guys I'm taking some
time off or listen guys I'm doing videos
once every other week and they've been
so cool about it and and yeah so there's
there's a lot of pressure but also I'm
trying to change my mindset and be like
oh these kids it's not like they're just
living for me they I'm just
entertainment now like five or six years
ago some of these kids were just like
living for YouTube and now there's more
mainstream does that make any sense I
feel like
there's less of I don't think any kids
are gonna kill themselves if I don't
release a video on Saturday you know I'm
saying I hope not
right and you're learning not to put as
much pressure on yourself err I mean to
deal with what it is that has become
your career and that has all these ins
and outs to it that and you got to find
a way to stay sane I mean the fact that
I'm saying well semi after this
interview I don't know well listen man
we we appreciate you sitting down with
us and and being candid and allowing us
to get to know you a little bit better
and seems like you should probably sign
the table ah we need a sharpie grab the
sharpie
there should be one around a lot of
Elvis memorabilia yeah that was a gift
no but you have other Elvis memorabilia
and other places here yeah we got the
Elvis clock from Memphis and then this
was a gift from his sister-in-law those
are the only two office things this is a
big sharpie I want you to what you
better make your mark all right
you get you get you can really go
anywhere you don't really have to come
this way even like Grace and Phil went
that way oh you want oh I thought this
was just like people only sign it where
they sit well everyone sits for your
city yeah I know that bar that is the
case do people ever try to sit over
there and you get mad because I noticed
you brought a special chair yeah yeah I
need some arms I need some armrests here
all right I'll sign it when I'm Duncan
yeah it's over we're done oh we're done
[Music]
there you have it our conversation with
Shane Dawson a man who used to weigh 400
pounds Wow I mean I learned a lot the
whole ghost thing
I guess if I saw my grandma as a ghost
first of all both my grandma's are
living so that's not possible that would
be weird it would be very sad if they
appeared as a ghost when they weren't
even dead but if if my dead grandma
appeared to me I would vomit too I'd run
into the hallway and I vomit it would be
I guess that's how I would react um
honey how would you react I don't know
well all of my grandmother's are dead I
have more than 20 how many do I have
I have none now I had two at one point I
had three grandfather's I haven't seen
any of they're all dead I was seen any
of them up is a ghost I'm sure you will
tell us if you have had an appearance of
a grandfather or grandmother in your
life and it changed your life like it
did shinza interesting conversation I am
enjoying doing this we got three of
these under our belts are you enjoying
this in your car in your home and your
earphones and your earbuds
making an ear biscuit out of this thank
you for listening we will do this again
next week yeah at least I will it's
gonna keep having it I will be here yes
I like having these conversations I
don't feel like something is being
accomplished and document I feel like
I'm learning something every single week
I hope that the people are learning
something every single week someone that
they find interesting thank you for
being here people listen to us next week
[Music]
[Music]